jean luc lahaye bonsoir bonsoir série
connaissent et jean de legge en cours
laurent baffie je connais moins bien
pourtant il vous torche au tennis assez
régulièrement il était éventé dans la
presse
c'est ma bête noire harry d'accord il a
jamais gagné à l'est et pourtant il sait
pas jouer je peux le dire c'est vrai
c'est tu sais comme moi je fais tourner
au ballet s'est entraîné quatre heures à
leurs jours vingt deux ans je vais la
tuer et prend deux roues de bicyclette
pas tout à fait pas tout à fait mais bon
à la douche milliers
escaré que la tension mais pense qu'à ça
il est super bien les yeux un plaisir
petite compensation aux antilles et on
sait combien pour les cartes
nvidia la caisse
rappelle des personnes
rappel des personnes bien alors jean luc
lahaye débarquer moi papa chanteur
appelle moi brando
jean luc lahaye donc avant de parler de
votre nouveau disque jean luc lahaye
jouer qu'on revienne sur une affaire qui
a défrayé la chronique vous aussi un
petit peu comme christine de les gens
courent la fermeture de votre boîte de
nuit depuis six mois et sa réouverture
comme une bonne nouvelle il leur
fermeture depuis 20 minutes ça vient de
tendre et
ça ouvre le 19 novembre lors des
alors voilà donc la boîte s'appelle 287
c'est pas loin d'ici d'ailleurs c'est
s'est plaint de saint denis
arias une vaste opération de police
alors à cause de trafic de drogue de
violence des vigiles sur les clients et
de détention d'armes blanches et d'armes
à feu
comme attendu puisque quelqu'un qui a
traversé hors des passages cloutés mais
ça c'est pas dans le procès verbal il va
s'expliquer non alors en effet il ya une
opération il ya six mois voilà
c'était sur commission rogatoire
à propos de travail illicite savoir
travail illicite selon bat encore
chanter
[Rires]
et en effet violence
vigilent sur certaines places c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai ça la drogue la violence
avec liant la drogue c'est absolument
faux laure est absolument faux il a été
trouvé aucune trace de drogue non 287
nanya lance pas de violence j'aurais
également et que c'était quoi après les
pubs si quelques-uns risque violence des
dix vigiles sur les clients et est aussi
détention d'armes blanches arme blanche
c'est faux armes à feu donc tout est
faux nom mais en vérité je crois que
tout le monde a lu
je
un certain journal très parisien le
parisien deux parisiennes le parent
explique noter un journaliste nommé
stéphane boucher oui c'est pas moche et
voilà qui d'ailleurs s'acharne sur
johnny également oui c'est vrai qu'avant
c'est honorable mais à mon avis c'est un
journaliste qui est couteau aux portes
pour vannes en année ce qui rentre pas
dans les boîtes aux lettres des gens lui
c'est quand même pas stéphane boucher
qui a envoyé les flics aux 280 ca du
tout mais stéphane boucher de me
persécutait depuis pas mal de temps par
là depuis certain nombre de mois à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un événement
aubervilliers entre un fait mineur
n'importe quoi la sphère été ramené à
jean luc lahaye du 287 1 en effet un
type qui traverse en dehors des clous
vols à la roulotte un viol à main armée
n'importe quoi on est des bons ça veut
dire que c'est lui qui aurait mis la
puce à l'oreille aux keufs il a
participé
alalala monter la pression à la
diabolisation du lieu en effet et
d'ailleurs il en a largement rajouter à
tel point que il y a quelques semaines
il y avait encore une demi page sur moi
dans ce
magasin ce journal c'est énorme de mes
pages au niveau de la maîtrise en
pratique d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je trouve
que il est sympathique parce qu'il parle
de moi c'est régulièrement faudrait que
lui envoie des photos assez récente et
c'est la seule chose que je puisse faire
de bien éventuellement si je le
rencontre un jour de le saluer lui dire
voilà est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
annonce quelque chose de réel un jour je
vais te mettre un bourre-pif recyclant
l'argent lutte sérieusement est-ce qu'on
a fermé cette boîte uniquement à cause
de boucher pendant six mois non c'est à
cause de lui il ya eu une intervention
de police à la suite de cette
intervention il a été relevé un certain
nombre
deux
infractions
concernant les primes non déclarées aux
salariés et en effet il y avait des
plaintes concernant le service d'ordre
ce depuis un an et demi et vous accusez
aussi un autre patron de boîte de nuit
parisien qui m'arrêtent il vous en
venant pas du tout ça ce set c'est bush
égalise oui oui c'est marrant ils sont
quand même nom mais des idées mais je
crois que s'il rencontre johnny lui va
avoir du souci à ce faire j'ai pas du
tout
donc voilà donc la boîte a été quand
même pleuré pendant six mois soit un
accident un accident industriel ouais
ouais bah oui puisqu'il faut payer tout
le monde les salariés les charges two
way et on rentre pas un centime de
trésorerie ouais mais moi je reste sur
un non dit m je comprends pas pourquoi
on ferme cet établissement alors je n'y
suis pour rien oui assez rouvert on me
dit
est ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci qui crie sa garde le bon client
voilà on donne des cartes de mon client
algérien j'utilise non non non non je
suis normal
avec cette carte à puce et moi qui n'ont
pas que je n'aime pas moustier qu'un
sapin et je l'apprécié mais je ne lui ai
jamais donné physiquement cette carte tu
n'étais pas là mais les valides fêté au
québec et qui distribue les cartes
pendant que c'est pas là sans déconner
c'est le monsieur en noir là je pense
que c'est moi que distribuer les cartes
ballon rond pourquoi il faut voter si
c'est valable ou pas
- 0 50 m qui signe une carte de bons
clients c'est génial l'emplacement ya de
quoi procède mise au point un truc quand
une carte devant clients peuvent venir
quand ivan gotti était passé comme ça
mais je
veux quand même on m'offre ça moi je
viens
très très bien vous venez parler de
votre livre oui tout à fait le livre qui
sortira nommé
et enfin ça vous il n'y a pas de
problème vous venez quand vous voulez
c'est sympa alors c'est quoi jean luc
lahaye ses vrais métiers protégés par un
juge d'instruction qui est en prison
aujourd'hui pour trafic d influence faut
aller tout est faux ce soir ce soir ce
soir vous êtes dans une stratégie mais
ça me rappelle deviers joncour au début
nos
quotidiens sur le dos il arrivé à moi
j'ai le monde d'aller sauter oui puis un
beau jour on se rend compte qu'on disait
la vérité comme halo d'achat j'en ai
dans les sérieux donc tout tout tout est
faux là il y avait un toit qui avait pas
de violence drogue avait pas d'armes je
ne vous n'êtes pas protégé par un juge
qui est mis en vous voulez parler de
jean louis voirain du procureur jean lui
voir un que je connais en effet comme
tous les gens qui ont des débits des
licences iv sur aubervilliers ouais
parce que c'est l interlocuteur au
tribunal aurait
au tribunal où je le connaissais et je
les ai rencontrés quelques fois on fait
les mêmes venez à mon anniversaire
lorsque j'ai donné un concert de 8,7
l'année dernière au même titre que 500
invités ouais vous ne vous êtes jamais
il n'est jamais protégé non il m'a
jamais protégé m'a prodigué quelques
bons conseils lorsque je basculais du
dîner spectacle
à la discothèque oui et c'est tout ces
deux attentats d'alger ou
alors jean yves hayez vous dénoncez
beaucoup de choses une aisance et une
enquête policière fait en dépit du bon
sens non c'est encore stéphane boucher
le
cdc
cdc mois cdc vont donc c'est pas vrai
vous avez jamais dénoncé une enquête
policière fait en dépit du bon sens pas
du tout c'était un article ça dans vsd
maintenant je le dis
si les babouches et alors j'ai pas
boucher non mais ça c'était même s'il
n'a pas des parts dans vsd
[Rires]
vous dénoncez une exploitation
médiatique contraire à toute déontologie
ça oui c'est bouché la wii mais toujours
bah oui il écrit il
écrira un truc à notre ami bush et s'ils
voulaient venir la semaine prochaine
venez venez vous répondre puisque
maintenant je serai présent sais pas si
tu veux tu as une carte de bon garçon et
johnny sera là aussi avec j'ai mis un
set à porter plainte et j'aurais pu le
faire ouais c'est pas dans ma
philosophie je porte jamais plaint très
je règle les choses différemment comment
quand je vois l'individu doit quand je
vois l'individu qui me nuit peut prendre
une part dans la tête je suis moi à
prise rapide non mais je sais qu'une
balade sur la scène moi je supporte pas
que je prends pas plein voilà est ce que
est ce que dans toute cette histoire
comme un petit peu difficile parce que
quand même une boîte préféré pendant six
mois c'est ce qu'il n'y a pas eu des
bons moments des foires par les
terribles sinon il portera pas plainte
mais
parce que terminant titres à plus de
bras
alors est ce que est ce que sérieusement
est-ce que nicolas sarkozy vous a aidé
pas du tout
il manie et dénis nuit gels et en dehors
de toute chose je pense que c'était vous
avez quand la boîte a été fermée vous
avez cherché à le joindre à détonner sa
bombe je l'avais vu auparavant c'est
encore une invention tout à fait encore
encore un mensonge éhonté de ce
journaliste boucher
bush est exactement vous voyez christine
quand même qu' il n'y a pas que vous
quel est désormais juste mais vous
pouvez interroger d'ailleurs le ministre
thériault oui ils vous confirmera que
j'ai jamais bien tenté nord a
rendez-vous en revanche il ya quelqu'un
que vous connaissez c'est jacques chirac
y avait longtemps que vous le connaissez
j'ai connu ou 287 pendant la campagne de
2002 il rentrera pas été tranchée par
une femme s'était vendu à l'appel
c'était une fête de l'internet
tout à fait il est venu faire un meeting
et dialoguer en direct avec les ânes les
internautes ouais mais vous le
connaissez de longue date et je le lance
et il tire il devance gery le luron qui
avait présenté il ya 22 ans comme très
proche absolument j'ai très proche non
mais c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé dit que c'est un ami
de longue date oui un ami de longue date
en effet parce que et lui dit je ne
connais pas cet individu il ya quand
même un problème
moi je pense pas qu'il dirait sache
qu'il a déclaré le seul tombe bien
voilà donc d'accord donc voila quoi donc
chirac vous l'avez appris non non mais
pourquoi leur plaît pas ce que je vais
vous dire un truc moi si on me fermer ma
boîte pendant six mois j'appellerai un
ami de longue date non non je pense
qu'il n'a rien à voir dans cette
opération je veux il a appelé d'autres
des fonctions qui n'ont jeu non non j'ai
appelé personne j'ai pas de relation
j'ai pas un tel ton nom sur les plaques
des motos et a pas de relation pour moi
pour un coût je suis parent de deux
motards de paris pratique la langue est
marraine un fait gaffe la marraine la
marraine et bernadette chirac et je suis
parrain depuis très très longtemps à
tuer puisque les actions n'ont rien à
voir c'est une passion je suis un motard
est bien mené c'est une passion étaient
des jeux pense qu'elle aime la moto si
que tu connais drucker j'aime bien sûr
c'est un vrai gentil
je connais pas intimement comme vous non
parce que moi parce qu'il est vraiment
sympa oui
oui non je fais pivot bros et pourquoi
il a arrêté pivot dans l'un des marins -
de bouquins je suis pas au courant dans
les pivots c'est pas un scoop mais
l'argent n'a 5 il est passé aux caisses
qui devient jean claude bourret on sait
maintenant je suis pas de la tour de
contrôle du paf c est qu elle danielle
gilbert daniel jaco newey voilà ces
données il ya des connivences je connais
je connais laurent baffie il est hors
jeu conséquent il ya un truc quand même
sur votre cd il ya une reprise que vous
avez fait de souquet l'étoile suis jeune
et oui et c'est vrai qu'en guise pour
croire en regardant en regardant votre
vie on se demande savez des fois il
faisait traîner c'est une drôle d toit
rue d'airé stéphane boucher j'ai un
destin sulfureux ouais non c'est vrai
vous avez déclaré je suis sorti de la
das pour aller en prison c'est tout un
destin qui est résumé en quelques mots
la légende de jean luc lahaye on va on
va là raconte évidemment il ya la date
fixée par les vous avez fait un bouquin
qui s'appelle sans famille qui s'est
vendu à 1,3 million d'exemplaires je
souhaite ça a beaucoup de potes à tous
les écrivains à tous les écrivains
ensuite bombe à votre mère
très très difficile la vie avec votre
mère votre mère distribuer des bibles
dans le métro elle forcer les gens à
s'agenouiller alors quand on se dit mais
pourquoi c'est qu'en fait votre mère
s'était jeté dans la seine pour se
suicider de la vaisselle voilà et il ya
une bonne soeur incroyable une bonne
soeur qui en voyant ça a plongé une
bonne soeur et un passant un âge bien
les bonnes soeurs on sent pas là avec
leur nette avec la corne est
non mais c'est vrai et donc à ce moment
là votre mère a été recueilli par cette
bonne soeur qui l'a envoyé dans le
périgord dans un couvent où elle devenir
un peu toc et de la religion catholique
on peut dire oui oui même ma mère
continue vivante elle est dans un
établissement spécialisé et dès qu'elle
peut sortir va prêcher dans la rue
partout moi je me souviens elle venait
me chercher à la dass quelquefois elle
avait un filet garni avec me souviens
baguette de pain ali de limonade serré
dressage et un paquet de bible tiens
distribué dans l'après midi dans le
métro m2 m1 très fort et regarder les
gens choisissait ses victimes me
souviens d'un monsieur qui lisait son
journal va tranquillement à lui arracher
le journal ce qu'ils voulaient pas
l'écouter le dit vous êtes un pêcheur le
gars a dit quoi que c'est pourquoi
mettez-vous à genoux mettez-vous à
genoux demandé pardon à dieu le gall
s'est mis à genoux parce qu'il a eu peur
et a fait l'abbé ni à la sortie de l'eau
bénite comme ça l'ue appelle à lui a
donné une bible dit lisez sa licence et
votre chauvin etc les portes sont
ouvertes sur tv qu'elle le ghana la
regarder comme ça moi j'avais honte et
puis elle a distribué dans le métro et
ses jours à la casse et des vides parce
qu'on voulait l'interdire faire don si
vous deviez vous dites et en parlant
d'elle qu'elle a été irradié par la
religion ça veut tout dire et alors très
bizarre ça quand elle venait vous voir à
la dass es vous apportez toujours des
oeufs de pâques par exemple oui quel que
soit le jour de l'ag qui vous êtes bien
renseigné c'est vrai on a vu la dass on
a vu votre mère votre beau-père achour
alcoolique et méchant ce qui fait que
vous retournez à la dass finalement on
préfère encore être à la dass qu'à la
maison tellement il est tellement
désagréable et enfin après 73 familles
d'accueil c'est beaucoup mais
quelquefois j'en faisais une dans la
journée 1 voir deux balles et un
après 73 familles d'accueil avec 200
balles vous démarrez dans la ville jean
luc lahaye et là il ya une scène assez
dur parce que je pense à stevie wonder
qui racontent la même chose c'est que
vous n'aviez pas de blé vous manger des
haricots verts à même la boîte faisait
chauffer la boîte sur le sur le gaz avec
un gant avec un gant de toilette oui
tout à fait oui j'ai fait ça pendant des
années ouais mais c'est pas un problème
oui oui la ligne n'est la peña rico il
n'y a pas de problème j'ai envie
d'ouvrir des boîtes quoi
mais ça c'est quand je m'éclatais parce
que les soirs de l'espoir de disette je
mangeais à même les rayons on a les
supermarchés ouais ça a duré combien 2 3
en 1
voilà alors ça c'est l'époque des petits
boulots à un moment vous êtes gardes du
corps et chauffeur pour zizi jeanmaire
et roland petit sans avoir de permis de
conduire j'avais pas le permis c'est
fort bas ou je ne sais pas si c'est fort
mais ils n'ont pas demandé ouais
c'est pas présenté j'avais je conduisais
une alfa romeo une rolls voilà enfin
j'avais pas droit à la roche mais un
soir j'ai prise et elle a fini place du
tertre dans un mur j'étais avec plein de
potes dedans
et là jean luc l'avez vous rencontré
gérard pedro restaurateurs de son état
qui va devenir votre votre producteur
peu après vous rencontrez dalida qui
vous loue le premier étage de sa maison
pendant trois mois je me demande
toujours bon je suis là j'ai l'esprit
mal tourné mais quand on est le garde du
corps de roland petit quand on loue le
premier étage de la maison de dalida
est-ce que ça s'arrête des rapports
professionnels ou non je sais que ça
concerne roland petit je vous rassure
tout de suite
et jamais on vient aussi pour dalida non
plus non non non
tu sais que hollande au xixe les plis
orlando et piégés
dans les galeries d'art donc que vous
louez le premier étage de sa maison à
montmartre le dernier piège tartam
héritage de dalida
et la nuit vous descendez à peu de la
cave pour vider le frigo nom d'abidal
pression
dalida les rides
s'est passé avec david s'est rien passé
et c'est une amie ah bon
parce que nous on pensait que la chanson
était à cause d'eux
18 ans arrivée il est amour
enfants photo m quelle belle chanson
quelle belle chanson pascal sevran et
joyeux oui et dalida et malou et le
dernier étage sa maison parce qu'elle
avait peur elle habitait seule assez
pour ça et moi et moi j'ai j'étais là
c'était rassurant port et quelqu'un a
mal et en plus je terminais ses frigos
en effet voilà un beau week-end parce
qu'elle partait en corse tous les
week-ends elle faisait des quantités
industrielles le repas pour des amis qui
venaient ou pas et il fallait terminer
moi je montais tous à la maison et que
les potes voilà voilà donc j'ai une
anecdote avec chéri de confiance et par
avance d par avance mais vas-y j'ai
rencontré en effet
jacques chirac qui m'avait été présenté
par thiery le lions club que tu es lui
même n'avait été présentée par jean
jacques debout voilà qui est maintenant
sorti de prison je crois que tout est
clair on peut compter et qui est
d'ailleurs était dans une cellule
voisine de jean louis voirain boire ça
va comme quoi les raids surviennent
cette émission
quoi placer alfatières vin café de 4
donné par à manger à jean jacques debout
les chinois insoupçonnées bras volant
alors on continue la légende de jean luc
lahaye donc après dalida il ya les
premiers tubes tout le monde connaît
l'histoire de la fondation la fameuse
fonda inauguré par françois mitterrand
il ne fréquente que des prisons la
république inaugurait par françois
mitterrand baby foot à la fonte d'art
davet voilà c'était d'ailleurs un moment
très beaux lots parce que l'histoire du
baby foot n'était pas prévu dans le
parcours du progrès et un moment ils
voient le baby foot il ya c'est un baby
foot jeux steam en effet monsieur le
président une partie est dit volontiers
je m'installe ici mais à côté de moi
déjà way sinon c'est par ici monsieur le
président et là c était incroyable il a
pris les joueurs par les têtes ah oui
mais bon j'ai lancé le président on
prend par la parole et nous a gouverné
pendant 14 ans
non mais bon bon alors voilà donc
mitterrand après chirac le baby-foot la
fonda et ensuite tf1
céline mozy qui vous présente jean luc
lahaye à monsieur francis bouygues pour
faire une émission qui s'appelle la haie
d'honneur à non plus tard faut dire
c'est fini un générique était débarqué
mois donc effectivement ça va pas durer
très très longtemps alors vous avez été
viré de tf1 jean luc lahaye au bout d'un
an quand patrick sabatier est revenu
parce que patrick sabatier des parties
sur la cinq ans quand il revient à tf1
vous êtes viré pour faire de la place
qua
non je ne sais pas si c'est petit c'est
une relation je suis pas
non je ne crois pas que ce soit
bien donc après il ya la traversée du
désert j'avais une traversée du désert
voilà personne vous appelle plus sauf
comme quoi tu vas le showbiz c'est pas
juste que des [ __ ] sauf michel
drucker est vraiment sympa grâce à m non
il m'a appelé
il a fait rodial peut-être canon non
mais la bouche est aussi inquiet non
mais m'a jamais appelé j'aimerais bien
qu'ils m'appellent
michel drucker m'a appelé un soir c'est
le soir d'anniversaire un 23 décembre
d'ailleurs je pensais qu'il allait me
souhaiter bon anniversaire appelé pour
me proposer de se rencontrer une taie un
coup de fil spontanée et tenter de me
secouer demi revient il faut faire un
album qu'est ce que tu fous c'est pas
possible cette situation mais qu'est ce
que tu as côté dépressif gênant mais
j'avais très bien mais je n'étais pas
dans un bon jour
pourquoi mais pourquoi il les boulistes
pas un peu
donc michel a été amical oui 13ème canal
qu'est ce que vous avez
mangé je voulais montrer grille
l'allemand dans le show business ils
sont pas tous comme ben ouais on
pourrait penser cette mais michel je les
ai pas vus depuis au moins dix ans mais
après ça complètement laissé tomber mais
toi je n'avais pas vu depuis dix ans je
remplace mais moi je t'ai jamais appelée
le 23 décembre de condenser regrettable
d'ailleurs c'est que ces capricorne
ouais comme date est capricorne ce sera
beaucoup pardonné bien alors à ce moment
là on aurait dû commencer par là encore
oui tu as raison continue la légende de
jean luc lahaye donc voilà à ce moment
là ses disques ne marche plus et là vous
aviez mais ce que je dirais pas que les
10 son revers et poussiéreux verrions la
ligne qui ne voit venir à jouer quand
est-ce que tu as joué contre moi tout le
temps
vous avez une prise de conscience jean
luc lahaye vous dites je suis tombé
amoureux de la gloire qui n'est qu'une
prostituée je m'étais pris à tort pour
un homme heureux là d'un seul coup vous
et vos yeux se disent ils et vous vous
découvrez l'inanité de votre position
c'est ça donc ça métier on doit assumer
absolument l'enfer et le paradis je
pense que c'est un métier extraordinaire
qui m'a apporté des joies fabuleuse et
puis mon des moments de solitude et
détresse et là on mange son pain noir et
on se plaint pas mais je me plains pas
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
gérard pedro décèdé et puis voilà quoi
et puis vous là où vivait l'enfer parce
que les gens ce qui est terrible quand
on est connu c'est que les gens dans la
journée il vit alors on vous voit plus
rien mais non mais soit se faire refaire
le visage soit changé c'est vrai que les
gens les gens disent on vous voit plus
souvent moi je dis bah là vous voyez là
mais ou alors bon
teint ou alors il ya des gens qui me
demandait aussi un moment
qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est ce que
vous donnez là je n'avais pas envie
d'engager le corps à 100 je suis
chauffeur chez ka bersone et même qu'un
jour on m'a cru
quand la 2e la note pas christine
kristin quand les gens vous voyez vous
pose des questions car il paraît bonne
est-ce que les gens vous demande ce que
vous devenez oui beaucoup oui et on leur
dit quoi
je survis
je ne suis pas morte c'est qu'il faut
remercier la ville
et toi les gens quand ils te vois et et
d'espoir maintenant ça va mais quand
j'étais dans la traversée du désert
c'était insupportable j'ai connu ça tu
vas les gros culs
très mystique et warta
k325 à découper
c'est le jeu la terre tu as peut être
coupée sur une mauvaise voie
c'est un couple etienne d'abord sécurité
après t'être fait adouber manie
bien non et tu es gentil tu quittes le
plateau
bien donc voilà donc effectivement c'est
la galère vous vivez l'enfer dispute
avec aurélie on va pas insister parce
que vous connaissez cette émission c'est
pas le genre non c'est pas du genre non
mais vous faites un morceau qui
s'appelle tu es parti sans laisser de
tendresse qui était celle qui est assez
beau jean luc lahaye voilà pour koné
majax ouais t'as vu ouais ben barka
nanterre
[Rires]
est alors bon vous revenez là
aujourd'hui avec une compil ou plutôt je
dirais la compil des compiles parce que
c'est il ya tout là dessus en vérité
crcd story sorti avec des titres inédits
première chanson produite par pascal
auriat d'ailleurs à l'époque qui n'ont
pas marché bien avant le succès c'est un
cd story mais sur mon album le 15
janvier un nouvel album inédit dans 14
nouveaux nous aurons les moyens d'en
acheter qu'un seul il vaut mieux acheter
lequel celui qui va sentir le 15 ou la
compil de maintenant t'es pas obligé
d'acheter tout en même temps tu fais des
économies du premier pour acheter lequel
celui qui se fait plaisir il y en a neuf
n'enlèvera rien
est ce que je peux donner ce que je peux
te placer la loge d'un bel objet à c'est
un objet relier un petit peu commun
comme un petit livre comme ça avec un
texte au début après il ya le cd tout ça
et le tu veux regarder le texte un petit
peu tu veux nous lire un extrait du
texte bien c'est très très beau
franchement je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas qui a écrit ce texte mais c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui m'aime bien abba qui
vous aime beaucoup c'est madame girard
au tournant sur le sofa je sens qu'ils
sont c'est excitant jacents et violacés
tc
[Musique]
jean-luc
avec ses rites
je sais les i
en attendant
pour être sûrs de nous inventer les
lignes habitudes abonnez vous mettez un
point merci d'avoir utiliser votre carte
de bons clients et d'être revenu alors
la semaine